alors nous sommes ici à villeneuve saint
georges c'est une municipalité située à
environ une quarantaine de kilomètres au
sud de paris nous sommes donc en amants
de la scène
ici c'est la rivière lierre qui se jette
dans la seine et qui donc contribuer à
faire gonfler le niveau ici donc il ya
eu inondations au cours des quatre cinq
derniers jours comme vous pouvez le voir
ici il ya énormément de maisons qui sont
touchés en fait 7 à 800 personnes ont dû
quitter leur maison
il ya environ 200 personnes qui sont
hébergées de manière urgente dans les
gymnases des écoles environnantes sinon
les autres personnes ont réussi à se
loger dans leur famille ou chez des amis
il ya encore des gens qui continuent à
habiter ici qui n'ont pas subi de pertes
de courant d'électricité ou de gaz qui
habitent parfois à l étage comme ici on
peut le voir mais qui ont deux à trois
mètres d'eau ou sous sol et qui devront
donc faire face aux conséquences de
cette inondation de ces inondations donc
au cours des prochains jours on s'attend
à ce que les niveaux continuent à monter
encore aujourd'hui et demain le pic
serait atteint au cours du week end avec
des conséquences plus ou moins graves
en aval donc vers paris là actuellement
bien sûr la scène était à des niveaux
assez important toute navigation est
interdite sur la seine à paris bien sûr
dans les musées on a vidé les sous sols
le louvre par exemple a déjà vidé tous
ses sous sols pour préserver certaines
de ses oeuvres qu'ils ont entreposés là
bas il n'y a pas encore de fermeture
comme tanya pas encore énormément de
conséquences graves mais bien sûr tout
le monde redoute la situation de 2016 il
ya à peine un an et demi en juin 2016 où
les niveaux étaient montés un peu plus
haut encore que ce qu'on prévoit
actuellement et savait et donc causé la
mort de quatre personnes et l'évacuation
de 5000 personnes dans la grande région
parisienne